this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
people who have lung conditions like
asthma or copd often take their
medications using a handheld device
called a metered dose inhaler or mdi
a metered dose inhaler sprays medicine
through your mouth so that it can reach
your airways
if your inhaler is not used the right
way some medicine may not enter your
mouth or some may remain in the back of
your mouth either way it may not reach
your airways where it is needed
this video will show you the general
steps for using an inhaler correctly
it's important to follow the
instructions that came with your metered
dose inhaler
a metered dose inhaler has three main
parts the mouthpiece cover
the plastic sleeve with a mouthpiece
and the medicine container
before using your metered dose inhaler
remove the mouthpiece cap and shake the
inhaler
if this is the first time you are using
your inhaler or if you haven't used it
in a while you may need to prime it
check the instructions for how and when
to do this with your inhaler as they can
differ depending on the type of inhaler
and medicine
when you're ready to use your inhaler
stand or sit up straight
breathe in deeply and breathe out
completely to empty your lungs
after shaking the inhaler put the
mouthpiece in your mouth and close your
lips around it to form a tight seal
as you breathe in through your mouth
press down firmly on the top of your
inhaler to release one puff of medicine
keep breathing in slowly through your
mouth for three to five seconds until
your lungs are completely full
it is recommended to hold your breath
for approximately 10 counts
finally breathe out slowly through your
mouth
if your medicine dose requires two puffs
you may need to wait before taking the
second puff
follow the instructions that came with
your inhaler to know how long to wait
between puffs
after using a steroid inhaler rinse out
your mouth with water and spit it out
it's important to keep your inhaler
clean so that it works properly
check your inhaler's instructions for
the right way to clean it
proper use of your metered dose inhaler
may help you control the symptoms of
your lung condition if you have
questions about the use of your inhaler
talk to your healthcare provider or
pharmacist ask them to watch you use
your inhaler to see if you are using it
properly
you